[Musique]
direction le grand nord pour notre
rendez-vous junior mélanie vazé nous
parler d'un roman jeunesse
on part en laponie avec techsoup un
petit ouf qui a des envies de voyage
dans ce pays du nord alors on suit ses
aventures dans cet ouvrage un ours au
pays du père noël un livre jeunesse de
véronique barbotin pour l'histoire
l'auteur qui vit à rambouillet nous en
dire un peu plus c'est un petit tour ça
qu'il arrive une aventure un petit peu
particulière que ce qu' eelv a souhaité
retrouver son grand père en laponie et
donc avant de préparer son voyage il va
passer par la bergerie par exemple de
rambouillet donc on reste en même temps
dans le local avant de partir pour le
grand voyage en laponie un texte assez
court qu'on peut lire petit à petit
avant d'aller se coucher
un os au pays du père noël est destiné
aux enfants à partir de 6 ans et
pourquoi pas des quatre cinq ans à en
lecture avec les parents et les
illustrations sont signées michel breton
un artiste pastelliste c'est vraiment
une rencontre où j'ai vraiment
l'impression qu'à chaque fois que
j'écris quelque chose dit michel
comprends tout à fait ce que j'ai voulu
dire
et honnêtement le personnage de
de techsoup a été inspirée de
l'association dont je vous parlerai mais
on est parti vraiment sur quelque chose
où les postures de textes où c'était
vraiment moi j'ai pas le talent de
michel pour pour dessiner et à chaque
fois lui on a l'impression que ça y est
c'est le prolongement crayon de demande
de cesser vos stylos cet ouvrage a aussi
un but caritatif
est-ce que 20 véronique barbotin et
michel breton ont décidé de reverser
leurs droits d'auteurs et
d'illustrateurs à l'association louis
carles et 6 mo alors cette association a
dead apporte pardon une aide
psychologique et matérielle aux enfants
est gravement malade elle organise des
voyages en corse en guadeloupe à la
réunion elle fait aussi des spectacles
avec des clones pour les enfants qui
peuvent pas quitter l'hôpital mais aussi
d'organiser des rencontres avec les
stars qui font rêver les enfants
de quoi se faire plaisir tout en faisant
plaisir merci beaucoup mais
l'anim'jeunes avoir présenté les
aventures de textos en laponie
le livre est disponible aux éditions pg
com